we're at a cattle market in the deep
south of madagascar the grand sued but
the thing that's most selling out here
is huge amounts of wood
only 15 percent of the population of
madagascar has access to electricity
it's one of the poorest countries
in the world despite its huge amount of
natural resources so inevitably the
people have turned to chopping down
trees to just provide fuel they also not
only use it for cooking but for heating
they sell charcoal as well as wood to
try to create a livelihood most of the
population are living on
less than two dollars a day
as i say one of the poorest countries in
the world but it's led to massive
deforestation which in turn has led to
soil erosion they've lost
about 40 percent of their forest
since the 1950s which has added to their
huge environmental challenges
if you look around most of
the people here have arrived here by
cart or they've walked they're one of
the countries in the world who
contribute virtually zero to the carbon
emission problem globally and yet
they're feeling the most impact of
climate change with huge extremes of
weather cyclones multiple cyclones every
year as well as huge long droughts
they've had an extended drought just
recently in some parts of the country
it's lasted for four years in other
parts of the country they haven't seen
proper rain in nearly a decade so the
problems here are enormous for the
population of madagascar